pues tras ser recibido Por los reyes de
España en el Palacio real Gustavo Petro
se ha dirigido y ha dirigido unas
palabras al parlamento español a mis
espaldas donde estaban presentes todos
los representantes de los grupos
políticos españoles excepto el de
ultraderecha vox que se ha negado a
asistir a este acto puesto que según
ellos Petro es un enemigo de la
democracia y de la Libertad en el
presidente de Colombia precisamente ha
dicho que en el se centran los ataques
de quienes no quieren cambios de quienes
creen que el mundo está bien así pero
que también en él se centran la
esperanza de muchísimas personas y que
teme no poder cumplir con lo que la
historia demanda del en su discurso de
media hora Gustavo Petro ha asegurado
que la política es vida que la política
es cambio y precisamente haciendo
mención a esto ha dicho que a ver qué
sale de la reunión entre la Unión
Europea y la celac prevista para el 17 y
18 de julio en Bruselas para ver si
mantiene el status y todo sigue igual o
se sientan unas bases diferentes un
cambio que el mundo está deseando Petro
dedicó gran parte de sus palabras a la
emergencia climática y e hizo un llamado
a los países a unirse en la defensa del
planeta puesto que según el presidente
colombiano no se puede ser una Potencia
de la vida sin la unidad de toda la
humanidad la visita de estado continuará
hoy con un almuerzo y reunión con el rey
de España y mañana con una reunión
bilateral con el presidente del gobierno
Pedro Sánchez
Marina ha habido protestas en oposición
a las visitas de presidentes
latinoamericanos con tendencia de
izquierda Esta no es la excepción
no ha sido la excepción mientras que
para Sánchez las visitas de Lula la
semana pasada y la de Petro estos días
es una muestra de la relación estrecha
entre España y latinoamérica para el
Foro de Madrid un grupo formado y
fundado por el grupo el partido de
ultraderecha vox estas visitas son una
afrenta al pueblo latinoamericano y una
muestra de la ideología
neognarco comunista como la llaman que
se está instalando en el Continente
además de ser un blanqueamiento de los
regímenes que han mencionado Como por
ejemplo Venezuela o Cuba una pequeña
representación realmente eran unas
cuantas decenas de personas estaban
denunciando frente al congreso de los
diputados que pese a que estos líderes
han sido elegidos democráticamente que
están cometiendo según ellos crímenes
contra la democracia y advierten del
peligro que tiene el comunismo para
España y para Europa